hey 42 here when we talk about the
origins of human flight
most of us automatically think of the
wright brothers
who first took to the skies in their
modestly named
right flyer in 1903 but
in reality this historic flight
was just one step on a long
quest that mankind embarked on more than
a millennium
earlier you're probably familiar with
the story of icarus
the boy who flew too close to the sun
only to fall back down to earth
and drown when his wings which he and
his father
daedalus had crafted from feathers and
wax
disintegrated it's a tale from greek
mythology that was probably conceived
to teach us that pride comes before a
very long
very deadly fall but as it happens
icarus and dedezales mad scheme to
escape from crete on jerry-rigged
bird wings is actually surprisingly
similar to some of mankind's real
first attempts at flight tower jumps
one of the earliest recorded tower jumps
was made by
andalusian polymath and inventor abbas
ibn fanaz
in 875 a.d when
he covered himself in vulture feathers
strapped a
carefully designed wing to each of his
arms
and launched himself from the tallest
tower in cordoba
like an enthusiastic participant in one
of those
red bull flug tags he's dead now
of course but that's because he was born
over a thousand years ago
not because he threw himself off a tower
and tried to fly
not only did he survive this daredevil
stunt
some accounts from the time suggest he
actually managed to
sort of fly for a little bit before
smashing into the ground at high speed
and badly injuring his back as a result
some historians credit abbas ebin fanaz
as the first human being ever to fly
though others believe his wing system
may have acted more like a parachute
slowing him down just enough that he was
able to
successfully not die on impact with the
ground
it's almost impossible to know for sure
whether or not
abbas ibn fanaz genuinely flew
and the same can be said for several
other somewhat dubious records of
human flight from the distant past
for example around 400 years before
abbas's time
rumor has it that chinese emperor wen
schwann
decided to punish several prisoners by
forcing them to leap from the top of a
tower
attached to very large kites most were
killed
but one yuan huang tao a son of the
emperor of a rival dynasty is said to
have endured the punishment
and lived to tell the tale then there's
ottoman
aviator ligari hassan chaliby
who in 1663 is said to have strapped
himself to 60 kilos of gunpowder
in istanbul and launched himself out
over the bosphorus
in what might have been the world's
first rocket ship
whether or not these men were flyers
fallers or
fakers is the subject of plenty debate
even today but these early pioneers
if you can call them that made some of
the first known attempts by humans to
fly
and mankind has continued its assault on
the skies
pretty much ever since if we want to
look at the first
confirmed flight of a human being we
need to fast forward a bit
to 1783 when a paper manufacturer
named jax etienne mongolfiere ascended
into the air over paris
in a rather splendid looking flying
machine he had designed alongside his
brother
joseph michelle not an aeroplane but a
hot air balloon
to give you an idea of just how
ridiculously limited
our understanding of flight was at that
time
just before jack setien's historic
voyage opened away the montgolfier
brothers
launched an unmanned test flight
i say unmanned but that doesn't mean
there weren't passengers
in fact there were three a sheep
a duck and the rooster this odd trio
were sent into the skies over paris
for one simple reason to find out
if it was safe up there the expectation
was that the duck and rooster would
survive the trip
no problem since both animals can fly
without
human intervention sheep on the other
hand
are absolutely pathetic flyers and
at the time it was assumed their
physiology was
pretty much the same as ours so the idea
was that if the sheep survived the trip
it should be safe for humans too with
the arrival of the hot air balloon man
had
if not exactly conquered the skies at
least
reached them and that taste of freedom
of looking down on the earth far below
as though pouring over a hyper-realistic
map proved addictive airships came next
the first of which the zhifard dirigibla
waddled its way punderously skywards in
1852. it seems the french had a bit of a
stranglehold on
aviation firsts in those days as it was
another frenchman who designed and flew
this one too
henry gifford and paris was once again
the location
for this historic moment both hot air
balloons and
airships are examples of what is known
as lighter than air flight
as the name suggests lighter than air
vehicles
achieved lift by virtue of weighing less
than the total volume of air they
displace
giving them positive buoyancy and making
them float
for exactly the same reason a cork
floats in water
lighter than air flight is fairly simple
in principle
and compared to its cousin
heavier-than-air flight
it's fairly simple to achieve in
practice too
sky lanterns you know those paper
contraptions with a candle inside that
hippies like to release at festivals
have been around since at least the
first century a.d
and probably a few hundred years longer
all the montgolfier brothers had to do
to build the first hot air balloon
was figure out how to scale things up a
bit
heavier than air flight on the other
hand
is another matter entirely it isn't
something most of us spend much time
thinking about
these days but it is really kind of a
miracle
that a 500-ton commercial jet can haul
itself six or seven miles into the sky
and somehow stubbornly stay there
to make that happen we humans had to
overcome a
frankly frightening number of scientific
engineering and technological challenges
these breakthroughs didn't come all at
once either the likes of leonardo da
vinci
galileo galilei christiane hargens
sir isaac newton leonard euler and
many many more of the brightest minds in
human history
provided vital jigsaw pieces of
knowledge
that would later help us solve the
puzzle of flight
arguably the first person to fully
understand how each of these pieces fit
together
was george kaley you may not be familiar
with that name
but kaylee was one of the true pioneers
of aeronautics
he was the first person to propose a
fixed-wing
flying machine with separate systems for
lift
propulsion and control and he identified
the importance of using
cambered wings to generate lift he also
clarified the four
forces that govern flight weight lift
drag and frost despite his mastery of
the principles
this last force frost was causing cayley
a major problem in his quest for powered
flight
he simply didn't have enough of it and
the technology of the day didn't offer
any way to get
more without dramatically affecting one
of the other forces
weight or to put that another simpler
way
steam engines were really bloody heavy
cayley did still manage to build the
world's first
heavier-than-air flying machine though a
glider that flew for the first time
in 1853 but he firmly believed
powered flight would be possible as soon
as someone was able to design and build
an
engine that was both powerful and
lightweight
and as it happens he was exactly right
in 1903 a few decades after the
invention of the internal combustion
engine
the wright brothers made their now
famous flight
paving the way for the development of
modern aviation
it's worth pointing out that the duo
actually hold a somewhat
niche first in the world of human flight
as we've seen they weren't the first to
fly
nor were they the first to fly a heavier
than aircraft
they weren't even the first to fly a
powered heavier than aircraft
that was another frenchman clement ada
who managed to skim along for some 50
meters
at an altitude of approximately 20
centimeters
in 1890 the official record held by the
wright brothers is the
first controlled sustained flight in a
powered
aeroplane which was admittedly an
important step on our journey into the
skies
but still just one step when you
consider that it took us around a
millennium to advance from
jumping off towers and hoping for the
best
to building what was basically a giant
sky lantern
and also hoping for the best
the speed of progress we've seen since
the wright brothers first flight
is actually pretty staggering by the
time the first world war came around
just over 10 years later aeroplanes had
advanced enough
that plane on plane dogfights became a
central part of warfare
a status they've retained to this day
after the war ex-fighter pilots and
other aviation enthusiasts
set about making the world seem like a
much smaller place than it ever had
before
john alcock and arthur brown made the
first
non-stop atlantic crossing in an
aeroplane
in 1919. and six years later
charles lindenberg became the first man
to make the trip
solo the first non-stop flight across
the pacific
came in 1931 and the following year
amelia earhart shot to stardom after
becoming the first woman to cross the
atlantic
alone more on her in an upcoming video
by the way
serious advances in the development of
the jet engine began to be made around
this time
though the first operational jet
aircraft wouldn't take to the skies
until the latter part of the second
world war
whilst it may have been late to the
party when it came to the war effort
this new technology would go on to spark
the jet
age during which the jet engine
completely revolutionized air travel
and changed the world in the process
jet powered airplanes were able to fly
much higher
faster and further than traditional
piston-powered planes
bringing just about the entire earth
within a single day's travel from any
given point
for the first time in human history
not only that but jet-powered planes
were able to be far bigger
meaning flights could accommodate more
passengers bringing prices down
significantly and opening up the skies
to
more and more people in 1961
humans conquered space the final
frontier
sorry when russian cosmonaut yuri
gagarin
took the vostok one where no man had
gone before i'll stop now
eight years later neil armstrong became
the first man in history to walk on the
surface of the moon
it's kind of crazy when you stop and
think about it
in the space of just 66 years less than
a human lifespan
we went from an almost unimaginably
primitive aeroplane
built by two eccentric brothers just
about lifting off the ground
to cruising through 000 239.000
of vacuum and landing on the moon
if your great or possibly great great
grandparents
happen to be born at just the right
moment in history
they may well have been alive before we
humans
mastered powered flight and after
we'd set foot on a world beyond our own
these days flight has become an integral
part of our world
well at least when corona isn't effing
everything up
air travel has opened up our planet in
ways our ancestors
couldn't ever have dreamt of allowing us
to visit distant lands
and exposing us to cultures we might
once have only read about in books
some of the pioneers in this video made
more important contributions to that
vision
than others but it's safe to say that
between them
they have fundamentally changed what it
means to be human
this hard-fought victory against gravity
through sheer human tenacity bravery
and ingenuity is arguably up there with
man's greatest achievements
or at least that's how it looks to us
but imagine just for a second what this
whole sorry story might look like
from the perspective of a bird to one of
our feathered friends watching
abbas ebin fanaz tar and feather himself
before leaping up a tower
half-maiming himself in the process this
millennia-spanning struggle of a bunch
of hairless apes just
trying to get themselves off the damn
ground is probably pretty hilarious
how many man-hours must we as a species
have put into our quest to fly hundreds
of thousands
millions and yet your average african
swallow
unladen or otherwise can do things in
the air that would make the world's most
advanced fighter pilot
wet himself whilst desperately fumbling
for the ejector switch
sort of put things in perspective
doesn't it
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube spotify
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcasts
link in the description below thanks